hi hi what's up not much like two weeks
T two weeks to III III madness setting
in yeah you're planning everything for
twitch right oh yeah the whole live show
you guys are gonna have a live show - oh
yeah I'm hosting oh that's awesome
I was last year its main stage or yeah
it's Lucy James and I well we're hosting
GameSpot's hosting our stuff from up the
boat the press conference from San
Francisco were streaming it from here
right so are you gonna be here during
the press conferences and then you go to
e3 to do the stages and appointments
stuff but yeah Lucy and I will be just
as last year we'll be heading up the
stage show that's cool we're doing
everything outside of the show floor but
in LA so it'll be really really good
when we're there but right now I'm like
super stressed out and this is like my
refuge is to like not frickin worry
about it we're not gonna like do any I
don't I think we're gonna explore the
Antarctic base I wanted to ask you I
found some bogan powder and I have 30
bows should I do that now or should I
like hold it because I actually don't
have them any like I don't have that
much going on here I got like 22 bullets
yeah you could also people in the
comment you need to buy know your
grenades they don't take up so many
slots it doesn't really matter I mean
like you can six isn't the maximum you
could do one oh are you saying as long
as they're same kind if they're blue I
can make that 12 and I can make okay
you know I there is no good reason I
think I was doing it cuz I was like
maybe I can make them like super explode
or something and I should kind of like
the bows where it's like you didn't want
to combine them there's no real good
reason to be honest with you I have no
good reason let me just back up out of
the singing so in the last episode I got
absolutely wrecked by some bugs and
they've like laying eggs in my butt also
full disclosure Mary was screwing around
before we went live
I found a sweet bookcase I told you kids
to stop screwing around pictures I asked
you push the bookcase that I okay yeah
let me full disclosure
that's not what I meant to do I need to
use this because I'm dying so I was in
this room minding my own beeswax and I
hate leaned on this and pushed it and I
didn't know I could do that so I'm gonna
go in here now oh my god just making
sure we're on the same page here it's a
rat don't worry it's a heavy turn around
turn around there we go
it was me I played I press the wrong
buttons hi I'm the butler and my name is
Sir Alfred oh nice no actually I think
sir Alfred is his boss which is weird
because typically Alfred is a butler's
name I've served your father Lord
Alexander and for so long shared in the
joys of Sorrows of the Ashford family uh
you like disappeared and stuff Alexia's
dead you were forced to become a master
of the family at a young age and like
now your crazy town I felt like could do
nothing I tried to ax myself and then I
was like nah I'm gonna live [ __ ] are you
talking about sincerely Scotty B
okay so there is a button here but it
operates on electricity so maybe
something for a later time when I have
electricity cool huh
there's no keyhole that's the thing that
what's-his-name was holding Lord Alfred
what it was like a fat indentation shape
Oh interesting
okay was there anything else that I
could possibly be missing in this room
did I already read this the t-virus
major didn't by ode genetics I've
disgraced my fam Spencer's gone too far
I'm gonna do a facility instead and it's
in the Antarctic where no one will find
me it will be similar to the mansion
which means it's just like a [ __ ]
crazy town the code name is Veronica the
research will revive her sick ass name
I'm really good at taking long memos and
kind of condensing them into their meat
you know shaving off the fat yeah you'll
embarrass the family so I tried to ax
myself but then I was like nah anyway at
keys in the locker brought shame upon my
lineage alright there's a [ __ ]
bug past here am I going to the right I
think so okay here we go
I'm pretty sure you can avoid them
if you wha let's try walking nope
alright
it laid Megan me wait
alright I got a second egg I got a third
egg it's three eggs no so gross
there's a lot I got a lot going on back
there hate that blue orbs are right
there I think you do I think you might
hey where's the leaving area right there
on the right
[ __ ] serious sucks this game sucks
now you're poison I think are you
serious let's find out this is [ __ ]
poisoned I just healed up I have like
eight eggs in my ass don't I god damn it
I think you're about to be poison again
all right listen let's see if I have an
egg behind me I think it might it's
honestly hard [ __ ] two more should I
just let myself be poisoned like what do
you mean to do I'm looking up I thought
there's a way you could deal with the
bugs that we didn't know at the time
just shoot them that's normally the way
I deal with things like this is [ __ ]
taking a lot of heat here
I wonder our last episode people were
putting helpful stuff in the comments is
it bullets is the answer bullets [ __ ]
have two more goddamn sacks on me he god
damn it Mary why did you get a tattoo
it's gone so don't be upset all right
I'm on caution already have all these
eggs all over me where are the
I'm sure where I'm going alright so
there's that why don't you just leave
the eggs in like has she considered that
so just avoid them it didn't work I'm
poisoned again anti Bo gas handle with
care what's this it's a power switch
alright that should be the last egg man
Stephen Sanders really doesn't like this
this screen setup it's too bad though
cuz we're definitely keeping it I've
heard nothing but good things yeah
except for this guy literally for your
comments in a row yeah I guess just
avoid them fossil are you poison right
now yes
should I go kill it try to but try to
avoid oh [ __ ] I'm actually really hurt I
think I can tell because my walking is
yuck yeah why'd you come this far while
being poisoned I don't know
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay so we're gonna shoot we're gonna
shoot the know don't ya know I'm going
to shoot them well you're wasting ammo
no I'm not I'm gonna get them no I had
eggs in me rats not gonna scare me this
time I was ready for you
don't bother wasting ammo here because
the moths will keep coming back well
it's not it's not about the ammo it's
about not getting eggs you're better I'm
dodging this are trying to I don't I
can't dodge them they're not having it
and there was a memo here process about
our strategy of saving before we switch
items we usually because we're playing
one Episode a week we usually we save
like on the hour which is not ideal
especially when you only have well we
also usually consciously [ __ ] good we
also usually save the item things at the
beginning of next episode of jogger
memory of what we were doing right and
you're not pointing no eggs on this back
baby oh yeah
golden all right that guy's dead now
there's an upstairs and there's a
downstairs
the downstairs the upstairs had a
there's a key that I wanted to show you
but it's not really that important so I
can't really do anything here right
because I need power
let's go up these stairs actually real
fast
I remember in grand theft auto 4 came
out was crazy to see you carrying
actually using the steps that wasn't I
don't think there's a first game that
was the earliest one I remember doing it
right so if I go down the stairs at the
same time what happens perfect
[Music]
help you like bullets oh I got it I took
a lot of bullies um I think I can shoot
this one so here if you go this way
check it out up what it doesn't look
like alright I gotta watch you okay I
think that guys coming no sigh trying to
remember this part actually so there's
there's here but there was also like an
earlier door weapons I wonder what's in
here
oh I really thought I had that one I
think I might have to kill these guys
yeah do it okay make it easier come back
through oh oh god I'm out of bullets all
right um I'm actually really short on
are you [ __ ] kidding me
my groceries space that's some [ __ ]
[ __ ] got hurt from
our dye have this something in here oh
my god oh god I'm out of [ __ ] bullets
what do I do
I like literally have nothing I can try
to lockpick him to death I saw that but
I don't even know how I get to it
what do you mean like I see it but I owe
the perspective dining room suite I
remember that room will keep going into
here first
okay can I jump on here sucks cuz I lose
all the damage I did to him but I can't
finish I can't finish the job
maybe really cool if this looped around
so that I
please be bullets they'll be so cool you
can open that probably using the
detonator although I wouldn't stand
right next to it when you use it what
you're about to do what do want me to do
get farther away from the c4 you're
about to detonate but I have to use the
detonator
yeah detonator is usually you don't oh
you're saying I don't need to be by it I
mean maybe I don't think you do
oh maybe you're oh I see what you're
saying like you have to be like resin
evil style you have to be a touching it
heat sensitive I need some no I was so
sure I had that Oh
do you not have a lighter anymore well
balls I could have used that like a
second ago tell me it has ammo all right
look guys super-dead balls does that do
damage to me minimal if any okay okay
later
so it's heat sensitive explosive is set
here so I need some heat baby man
for a room that's like all about guns
and stuff it doesn't have a lot of guns
okay I guess that's it alright was that
it I think so it's really bright sorry
it's very dark in this room in the game
but the lights on the monitor make it
hard to see sometimes all right so
what's up these stairs I'm pretty sure
[ __ ]
consider yourself juked idiot okay
upstairs I will discard that key alright
hopefully there's like some bullets in
here and some help
and some like you know not zombies
this room's weird like at a first glance
I'm like I'm gonna get some kind of
disease from being in here you know like
vapery like when Marie Curie was like
I've discovered it radiation [ __ ] like
what is all this empty space weird very
blue okay up you go be a boss fight or
something
god I hope not I don't have the health
or the ammo and bring anything with me
an octagon-shaped hole and a notice
poison gas in case of emergency seal off
okay so I need an octagon thing which I
don't think I have I don't think I have
any octagon thing so this whole room
like denman I should actually be
checking my map more I feel like I've
been missing stuff cuz I like
all right I don't see anything thoughts
feelings expectations there's another
door out of here I think one door this
yellow door then there's this black ship
you know there's a yellow door at the
bottom that you didn't use dragon I just
hope there's no bugs ever again
really over the whole bug thing you know
I [ __ ] hate dogs
I hate killing them no there's other
dogs there's multiple dogs now there's
so many dogs there's like three times I
am so I'm sorry I'm sorry imagine if
there were French cheese
so please stay down I don't enjoy this
[Music]
yo that dog needs to just [ __ ] die
sweet I definitely killed that last one
let's show that guy like 30 times
there's a seal here I wonder if I was
supposed to eat wait wait go click on
that Valve I was like run from it
doesn't want me to I know it looks like
I should though doesn't it is there
anything in here
[Music]
it's weird talk that's where I came from
one more time let's do it
here we go
[Music]
that looks important let's go touch that
power the turbine alert made it worse is
that the only thing in this room no
there's other stuff I don't know
it's dark and I'm like having trouble
seeing I want to keep trying
rest assured I'm gonna solve this riddle
Mike where's the Navi no farther up
this way yes
two herbs right there on the ground Oh
nice
all right but is there another door
besides that one like what's this hole
like there's a hole upstairs here
open the map is that a door
no no
the circle I think I'm I gotten
everything no you haven't
yeah I appreciate I did I'm pretty sure
you didn't just go here go try to pick
up stuff on the ground there okay
there's bullets in here too really man
apparently three more herbs three
how do these people see this stuff
well they're back there again
oh I see them yeah yeah yeah yeah girl
yeah you're in the hot seat yeah no Reds
again though isn't that weird how they
always give me greens more bullets up oh
I see them this is gonna fill up all my
I'm a little items there I could combine
two greens if I have to if I find
another item okay cool good job so I've
gotten the power working which means I
couldn't maybe push one of those buttons
outside of the down these stairs like in
this area the room of going into right
now there's got him what a [ __ ] idiot
I'll push it the switch it seems that
the power is not being supplied did you
not see the generator I just put a lot
of effort into let me think what else
needs power no in the save room there
was a button behind the save room yeah
but there's still stuff go back to there
don't like backtrack go back
I got it I got it
come this way this is the other side of
the sorter okay there's something with
that conveyer belt they ate this guy's
goodbye oh man
hey where's Dylan just came just [ __ ]
killin nope
yeah got it you're not gaining anything
by keep him there you're gonna just lose
health again yeah that was the number
one I went back to everybody had from
not this time cuz I'm gonna do you go
through here at ya okay so was there
more area or no wait you haven't come in
here yet I'm there
oh my [ __ ] god what is that that's
not funny
oh there's something behind you on the
wall
gas masks lock releases if a gas leak
occurs is it the mouse again you really
handle that well shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] how do ice kill these things I mean
you're doing the right thing it's just
nice hey Dad too much advance too much
spider life does don't kill yet I'm
gonna die
see goddamnit there's another one where
is it it's under the floor I don't think
you can get it
just keep moving oh god that's the thing
that's the thing
Lord box remember said I was missing the
barcode Oh No
the box on the conveyor belt in the
previous room oh I think there's other
stuff in here well I don't like this
room
oh I see it too herbs those things
[ __ ] me up so bad I minor in handgun
stuff and your bows your arrows actually
first make so combine your handgun
rounds oh okay so then put the regular
bows I'd say in though it's better than
what I had I think I still need to
combine no don't just go put the barcode
on the box and then come back for the
syrup it's worth the extra effort okay
what about up here though I don't think
you can climb up there I think you need
the box to get into here for whatever
reason maybe it's got an tired spider
[ __ ] Jew should I change some more
bullets on there too
should I change guns and oh that's a
blue herb yes
oh well then yeah I'd combine that with
the green then cuz I might have gotten
poison from that spied I don't think I
did that night this but it will be
actually no don't combine it yeah you
don't know when you're gonna I think
it's better until you just get rid of
the barcode turn around [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
that spiders those spiders suck oh
alright gross alright so you got that
zombie in the next room right but I'm
totally not gonna die to him correct and
then there's this area that you can't do
anything in until you get the that
octagonal valve thing okay that was so
we want to put a barcode on the thingy
yeah how do we do that
come back this way just work this out
okay I got it
wait I went I do too much hey I might
you're trying to cast the defensive
spell on it goddamn it and went too far
right oh no wait where's the box it was
in please just kill him he's so annoying
where is it behind the barcode I think
you just use not about right there you
mean put the barcode on the box
I got it
now can you do the switch maybe
oh come on please be done all right
hmm there's still no power so maybe what
I was saying was is there was a button
behind the save room that had a that
said it had no power but I don't know if
that's connected oh you turn the power
on in the room with all the dogs that
should have powered this did you did it
something else the generator is on hmm
go back to that room no I'm not I
believe you I agree with you but I think
there's something else in that room that
we didn't do all right
I forget what your room it is it's in
here no yeah yeah no this is the spiders
you're right
it's up the stairs right yeah just
[ __ ] spiders awful I can't believe I
like triple juked myself
all right and then it was like that's
like an eject button under the door the
lock
okay so generates definitely on kitchen
you go up to the generator now I never
saw stairs
like I never saw any like there's
obviously an upstairs
but I never felt like I could get there
you know
do you see anything I'm missing
like those herbs and the guns and all
the other stuff that I meant forgot
go up to this lever again you see what
it says it's working
what's back there is anything like that
cabinet thing to the left because on
that or there right it did work
no this one did but why didn't the one
about with a box that should have do you
think that the maybe there is a second
button
wait what about that valve I don't know
like probably grasping at straws right
now I think so
okay well that the electricity valve
and all the van
I think it's possible I missed a room go
back into this other doorway from here
okay you mean like up here yeah yeah oh
this one might be on now no wait this is
the one we're also going to examine it
anyway poison gas in case of emergency
seal off I mean the thing you like you
said the thing you can do is go back to
that locker and the save room and
there's a button there I just don't know
what it does it'll work I know but that
leads to do those bugs I know
no step we're missing but I think there
was another door I missed somewhere I'm
gonna go past here and into here into
the weapon room
so dark okay yeah I guess just go back
to the save room I might be thinking too
far at head I don't know I think I'm my
own
cuz there's this heat set explosive yeah
oh yeah just go back to the saving like
that's the bug
I hate those but you're gonna have to
come back here anyways for the valve
thing so maybe something else will
happen when that will trigger it yeah
you know I feel about the bugs though I
know
hey I don't enjoy them beating the [ __ ]
out of either I hate it the most though
because they plant X in my back it's
very disturbing a lot or it's just a
personal like I don't like it I like
stuff yeah worth it nice totally worth
shooting that [ __ ] off insects alright
so there's a insect incest
so we have a generator but we don't have
electricity that's what's happening I
don't know what that means
but that's where we're at those spiders
look like they were on multiple levels
but I could only get on one level was
there more in there that I was missing
no I'm gonna go past these bugs okay
mm-hmm
they're gonna lay an egg in me I just
know it Oh balls lemme lemme lied I mean
we're just probably missing a button er
somewhere because like okay here's the
thing the generator is on and it's
working but there's no electricity so
I'm just missing a simple like power
thing it's very close did I miss a power
switch we just went to the weapons room
so it's not that is it in the bug room
and I missed it maybe there's like
something in here [ __ ] I hate this room
I hate bugs so much
oh god I hear it my god I hate I hate
him I like wanna kill it and I can't
what's in that back corner that way
tear the left now that was our ladder
down there toward the camera right now
go around the capsule and come back
toward the camera it's weird though
isn't it I'm like worried that like it
it's so like I know like people might be
seeing the stream but like maybe we need
to turn the brightness up wait
okay read that again that releases when
there's gas right so and then there's
gasses in the Box it all there's
something missing with the box there's a
lot of gas going on here this is all gas
related as usual hmm check around the
control room again the the one with the
box okay this one can you check the map
yes
so that's the mining room you've been
there that's the B EOW room that's the
weapon room like this room might have
something that you do okay so like this
is the meat of the check-the-box now
that you put the sticker on it okay
bound for B or W warehouse okay so
that's good the power's [ __ ] on I
know that's why it's [ __ ] annoying
check one of those switches again just I
know you already
triple-check power switch yeah there's
no power being supplied okay so it's
something in this room maybe go to the
other side of that
Oh cartridge let's go to the other side
of this machine
yeah keep coming to the camera yep yeah
keep coming this way so you're on the
other side now it's really annoying
I feel like we're super close that's out
it's back to bug town and I don't want
to go to bug town and there's definitely
like nothing up these stairs is the
mining room I guess let's just check
check the [ __ ] generator room one
more time if there's a generator room
yeah we've been in here like this room
ain't got nothing
so there's nothing here not that I
[ __ ] see that's the thing there's how
early and upstairs that I don't know how
to get up there alright let's take our
little walkie-talkie time here okay
check map is there any door I know oh
wait wait wait go back okay
that stairs goes to the Octagon
is there something back up those stairs
or that's just toward the beginning
right
I swear
I thought that would change the floor
like maybe just
we've been in this room
you know like what's back there
I'm just like touching everything but I
don't know no go that way first nope Oh
like down this corridor
I know but it's not really
like Oh and after that way
see back here yeah and this is the
[ __ ] eggs
but there's this clear catwalk here oh
my god
donor how long that's been there and I
wonder how torturous this one's for
people watching so now press that that's
probably conveyor belt oh there we go
that's so [ __ ] stupid this game is so
dumb
oh the power generator is on another
button we never went in here yeah okay
well sweet now we can this is not the
shows
hopefully our viewers are drunk you're
good now
oh there's now we can [ __ ] see there
is five herbs in here there were five
herbs in here
I think there always were I just there's
a pre-emptive the middle finger to all
the people saying oh my god just going
there 90 years
all right let's mail that package oh
sweet there's music and everything it's
bright
now you can press that switch you can
press the Locker switch
deliver this Bo w box that spider room
but that's sometimes okay but that's
this that's the res evil games Explorer
now we know the map really well
so that should have gone into the spider
room I think
what was the point of that first switch
though can you wait hon before we do
anything else just to double-check come
back around to behind the conveyor belt
sure so all the way over here yeah
sweet nothing okay
now the spider DFW room I guess is that
spider to me alive in there might be
like can he get out from under there
I wasn't a weapon room you might need to
go there first that poison gas hideout
yeah you can get the gas masks now I
might have to combine and green and blue
well yeah am i poisoned no you should
probably heal up knowing you could
probably do a green and a green and then
use that and then eat it yeah you're on
orange
yes now and then do me they like put
this on yeah just to be safe
just just having it in your inventory do
anything I don't know I guess it's not
poisoned yet but at least you're out of
it I mean it [ __ ] looks like poison
God yeah now go over to where that
conveyor belt was broken [ __ ] you box
there so the vo w gaps were in the box
so hopefully yeah the box is right there
yeah what do I do
leaking anti B Oh W gosh
okay so
what what just was there something
inside that flag
that spiders so much fun
try using the I know this wait yeah I
know this sounds counterintuitive but
now there's an herb nice I guess
try using the L we forgot about better
this sounds all wait
I wonder you're supposed to shoot the
tank with my bullets that'll kill the
spider I don't know what that will do
though actually
check the box one more time okay
so that seems good anti bo w powr your
enemies let me go check the weapon room
okay the other one and then weak now the
powers on it goes press that locker
thing right
you go to the door at the end I think
yeah right sorry I don't think there's
gonna be anything in here but can't hurt
cuz you did transport another box
somewhere well there was the lighting
the thing where it was like there was
the shiny thing that moved yeah as I'm
saying it that was another box I think
oh Lord
something I can't get no so this is
probably the fire extinct at the Magnum
that we don't have
can I like run past it I think it'll
just push you back I really needed that
fire extinguisher that really sucks
I want to make fan art for the show and
it's just a fire extinguisher and it
says never forget never what we did
Charlie Brown song the sad one
beautiful what am i doing save room and
press the button but
do not [ __ ] come near me I'll kill
you why is this area look different the
lights are on oh yeah all right I'm
gonna run for it [ __ ] worth is that you
yeah
I try to think if you could save now or
what is it wait I went in oh my god
[Music]
in the cord legit creepy
[Music]
what if it goes down go back in and get
that thing in the corner stop being a
baby [ __ ] hang out that guy tonight
shut then
[Music]
can I like either you hear only useless
books you check the plant pot or
something sure why do they have to say
plant and you're poisoned by the way
what when no no you have that blue herb
though
should I use it no you should probably
go to the well if the bugs get me I
think I could die how did I check the
pot and then something is post here
oh wow that was a while ago that's like
back upstairs
remember radical Kees the company a
minute well that was the episode
really you can either cure the poison or
cure it now that's okay or save I'm
gonna cure it and then do it next time
I'm gonna cure it what if you die and
then you've lost all our long progress
that's [ __ ] rude I'm not oh my god oh
my god how are you not poison anymore
did it wear off I guess no but you're
about to be boys I know because I have
an egg in my ass
my recommendation you probably only
thought this go through the double door
near you and let the egg hatch get
poison and then come back through heal
alright well no I should heal now right
and then cuz the poison doesn't curing
poison doesn't heal you it just gets rid
of the poison if you use one blue air
but if you could you combined one Oh at
the potting yeah so I'll just [ __ ]
take an egg out of my goddamn body eat a
blue herb and then that should cure me
right yeah yeah
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] Maude
I'm actually really freaked out that I'm
gonna die
I should've just eaten the blue herb it
won't it won't set it will say you have
no use if you're not poisoned
I meant before I was in the same room uh
no I think you did I if I'd known it
would have worn off well you you
wouldn't have had to eat for maybe this
eggs just a part of me now
his name is grumpy I guess go back to
the save room what I'm saying that the
portable blue herb is much more hanging
out just covered my I guess just go back
I don't know maybe at some point some
[ __ ] honestly
it's a goddamn mods I hate these things
so much
[ __ ] you okay and then let's find out
how I'm doing all right I'm stalling
caution so we're okay all right [ __ ]
abs worth no regret
I hate those ruble check that you're not
poison okay
check my back for eggs we good cheese
this thing suck
alright so next time you don't need a
gas mask right hand guide say yeah next
time we're going to that room what room
the machine room
yeah that's back toward the beginning of
the face I got a start I'm out of save
slots so I got to start going back to
one here yeah I'll be out got some stuff
done got power on I mean it wasn't like
the most productive episode because I
like didn't realize how to turn power on
but that's what happens in these games
you're playing for the first time or the
first time in like 8 years in my case in
your case sweet still good thank you
joining everybody um what is today today
would will be Saturday when people are
watching yeah it's the week yeah we have
Monday off and it's the last I think
it's the week before e3 or my nuts yeah
well no but the week before you 3 you
will be doing stuff because the week
before e3 I go to LA to set up for e3 I
figured out well heaven we might have to
do a double assad soon because I'm not
gonna be able to do anything for e3 okay
as usual but I mean we're probably not
gonna like
we're probably not gonna show the
episode during e3 because there's like
III stuff well postpone it all right
we'll figure it out thank you guys and
have a good rest of the weekend and
happy Memorial Day sure yeah if you're a
veteran I know there's a few veterans I
watched thank you so much for your
service and hopefully you get to enjoy
Memorial Day my brothers in Iraq so but
I get to FaceTime with lot so I'll
hopefully talk to him it's awesome
well it's awesome it's there it's
awesome lady serves dad served mm-hmm my
brother was Marines eight years and then
now he's Army counterintelligence for
the last four it's crazy he's still in
there my my dad was a an army uh it
wasn't a general but he was like a guy
who told people what to do and then he
and her and then he like left sergeant
he endeavor very long a general pretty
high I think he kind of did it you know
for tenet for college stuff and then he
was like oh do you do like our ROTC I
think yeah recruiting officer training
yeah I think was like in yeah yeah my
brother was an NCO which is like when
you become an officer
you're a noncommissioned officer if you
start with what you can go like anyway
thanks again yeah and thank you guys
thank you all for watching and hanging
out with us again good enjoy Saturday
enjoy the three-day weekend if you're in
America see you later three-day weekend
its weekend one extra day coffee's fine
our Bush wanted to bring back four-day
weekends I